hallo mein name ist yukon herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
gehört wahrscheinlich schon an meiner
stimme und zwar ist die ein bisschen weg
ja deswegen habe ich mich wahrscheinlich
gerade an wie ein komplett anderer
mensch ihr seht schon dass wir heute
algari o spielen
sie lag dass hier gerade ein bisschen
oder komme ich dir nach ihren gegner
jetzt gehe ich noch hier
ich bin einfach zu mir agrarium bis hin
zu viel lag zocken wir jetzt einfach mal
die bio ich meine ich find das spiel ehe
eigentlich cooler als addario also wir
gucken einfach mal ob wir jetzt einfach
ein bisschen mir kommt es vor als ob man
bei diesem spiel direkt im krieg ist ich
wollte heute eigentlich erst gar kein
video hochladen weil ich wirklich heute
morgen aufgewacht bin und die totalen
halsschmerzen hatte ich kann auch gerade
echt nicht richtig reden ich bin heute
morgen einfach aufgewacht und hatte halt
die übelsten halsschmerzen hat echt gar
nichts trinken essen bekommt wirklich
sofort ob ich mich in letzter zeit nur
eine gesundheit beschwere ich habe mich
beispielsweise letzten schon darüber
beschwert dass ich totale
rückenschmerzen hatte ich habe probleme
mückenarten und sondert wirklich
überhaupt nicht so rüber kommen dass ich
irgendwie youtube plattform nutzen um
mich immer mal
gesundheitlichen zustand abzufangen aber
es ist halt einfach so dass ich in
letzter zeit vielleicht ein bisschen zu
viel draußen war wenn man nicht hätte
draußen sein sollen also im regen
schwimmen gewesen irgendwie im freibad
dann bin ich beispielsweise gestern bei
13 grad um zehn uhr abends cabrio
gefahren wie ihr vielleicht man das
laptop story gesehen habt ja wir haben
eine wasserpistole aufgefüllt und kühle
nass gemacht aber keine sorge da ist
nichts großes passiert oder so nicht
dass tierschutz jetzt mein soll das
macht man nicht ich bin übrigens gerade
schon bei der 24 das eigentlich richtig
gut gerade ein paar sekunden später what
the [ __ ]
ich konnte diese dreiecke nicht
abschießen ich dachte ja ich mache kurze
pause weil ich kann nicht so lange am
stück reden mit meinem hals und dann auf
einmal werde ich einfach abgeschossen
und ich war will 24 alles klar
und jetzt level 12 wieder eingestiegen
und arbeite mich jetzt einfach mal
wieder langsam hoch ich hatte früher
aber wirklich eine ganz gute taktik
eigentlich also ich war relativ stolz
auf mich gerade sogar ich hatte heute
uni und habe quasi in der uni halt
hauptsächlich um einen ablaufplan
gekümmert also was ich die nächsten tage
hochladen werde und so weiter und so
fort und da waren halt ein paar videos
dabei die ich heute halt wirklich echt
gern hätte aufgenommen aller die kommt
nicht würdig jetzt mal eben rock you
will know me der erste kill den ich
irgendwie gemacht habe glaube ich und
ich hatte für heute halt wirklich
irgendwie wieder ein live video geplant
weil ich in letzter zeit einfach gemerkt
habe dass wir live videos bei euch
einfach so unfassbar gut ankommen
irgendwie jedes der letzten wirklich
viel mühe mitgegeben harten schnitte und
so hatte fast gegen die 800.000 aufrufe
oder so das ist ultras und das ist also
ein richtiger motivationsschub also es
war eine zeit lang so dass sie meinen
kanal irgendwie hatte ich irgendwie
50.000 neue abonnenten im monat gemacht
und jetzt diesen monat sind seitdem die
letzten tage mal so fast über 3000
gewesen das sind halt einfach immer so
richtige motivationsschübe und da hat
man dann einfach keine lust meinen tag
zu sagen nee ich nehme jetzt heute kein
video aufwiegen
halsschmerzen oder sowas deswegen habe
ich mich jetzt dazu durchgerungen ich
wirklich jedes gesetz hat mir gerade
noch ein schmerzender ein gehäuse das
ist nicht ganz so weh tut
in meinem rücken video haben viele
gesagt luca de simuliert doch und so was
alles aber ich habe mir da wirklich
wärmepflaster gekauft und auch
schmerzmittel genommen so dass das ganze
team wieder läuft also mit meinem rücken
ist alles wieder in ordnung kommen ich
hab sogar noch ein gekillt diesen salé
oder so 'oh mein gott wie viel wird denn
hier gerade rom geschossen
oh mein gott meine stimme ich meine auch
wenn unter dem rücken video einige
meinen luca das denkst du dir doch nur
aus jetzt gerade kann man glaube ich
nicht sagen dass ich mir nur ausdenken
weil meine stimme wirklich vollkommen im
eimer ist und ich kann wirklich muss er
auftrat pausen einlegen weil ich dann
einfach wieder einmal komplett
durchatmen post bin übrigens gerade
schon wieder auf level 24 will heute
einfach mal so weit kommen dass ich das
doppelt wieder irgendwas anders dran
machen kann also dass ich irgendeine
grössere maschinen werde oder
sondermaschinen sniper kombination war
ich ja auch schon mal als wenn alter
diese ganzen kleinen ekelhaften dreiecke
verfolgen mich aber die ganze zeit da
kommt ja man ich habe jemand getötet
okay du dich hier noch jemand ich nehme
einfach mal da jetzt so soll es packe
ich mir hier so welcher drauf okay gut
war man beim jetzt geht's ab freunde bam
bam bam bam bam bam bam bam bruder du
bist auch tot so da hab ich schon wieder
dom habe ich schon wieder getötet einer
der drei und da ich jetzt halt so mit
der stimme so ein bisschen am arsch bin
habe ich halt erst gedacht ich neben
stunden video aufgeteilt wirklich so tue
also wo ich als zocker und dann so tun
als ob ich rede
allerdings hat einfach keinen laut von
mir geben das ganze eben diese
pantomimisch versuchen darzustellen das
wäre allerdings im schnitt ultra
anstrengend gewesen weil man da einfach
halt nicht richtig weit okay wo setze
ich jetzt genau car2go das heißt bei mir
jetzt gerade beispielsweise auch schon
wieder 15 minuten lang deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht nee du komm ich lass das mal
lieber und zog einfach ganz normale
runde und versucht zu kommentieren und
entschuldige mich einfach dafür dass
meine stimme total am arsch ist dass es
eigentlich so dass home video thema und
deswegen wollte ich jetzt ein bisschen
mario als hintergrundbild
aber irgendwie immer so ein bisschen von
mir töte ich noch mal eben schnell ein
mein gott okay okay das schaffe ich doch
nicht es ist echt unnormal wie lang man
bei level 38 braucht um irgendwie mit
den ep punkten voran zu kommen
ich war schon die ganze die sachen ab
und auch in welche gegner aber es dauert
halt echt jahre er wenn ich den töte
kriegt doch locker richtig viele
erfahrungspunkte oder com bruder bruder
bitte just died motherfucker oh mein
gott ok ich hab ihn getötet bekomme
jetzt hier ein paar sachen ich bin level
43 so gut war ich noch nie das einzige
was ich unbedingt noch mal erhöhen
möchtest der mouvement speed weil ich
einfach fakten langsam wie eine
schildkröte bin freue ich mich auf platz
vier übrigens ne also ich weiß nicht ob
ihr das gerade eingeblendet seht da
recht wahrscheinlich nicht weil ich das
herausschneiden musste aber ich bin
platz vier ich habe jetzt gerade doch
nicht den mut mit speed erhöht sondern
einfach mal den bulle damage damit ich
jetzt quasi einfach in solche sachen
hier komplett rein schießen kann kann
sein dass es nicht höher als semmel 45
geht ich kriege unten ihnen wie keine
neuen erfahrungspunkte auch wenn ich
hier noch so viel von diesem kleinen
chip balawi geht was er da schon wieder
von deutsch ich will das video auch
eigentlich gar nicht so lange machen wie
ich sonst immer mache also ich habe in
letzter zeit den durchschnitt der videos
echt so von fünf minuten auf 8 minuten
erhöht ich hab schon wieder ein annahmen
tank diesmal gekillt das ist jetzt
gerade echt zu einer der besten runde
ich bin platz drei gerade sogar es ist
gerade einer der besten runde hatte ich
habe schon wieder annehmen tanke gilt
allerdings liegt das video gar nicht so
lange halten weil ich meine stimme nicht
so viel beanspruchen möchte ich habe
schon wieder jemanden getötet
ich bin ich wert gut in dem spiel ja
freuen ich finde es in der 120 minuten
ich will ja nicht dass das video jetzt
irgendwie unter lang mit weil ich ja
wirklich meine stimme ein bisschen
schonen möchte das tut mir leid aber ich
war jetzt ein extra zum leader hin der
ist oben links das sieht ihr vielleicht
gerade eingeblendet ich bin runter
rutscht auf platz vier gerade weil ich
gerade gar nicht mehr geschossen habe
aber ich war zwischenzeitlich kurz
weiter was schon relativ gutes für mich
ich werde die ganze wieder von dem
blöden dreiecken attackiert ich weiß
nicht ob die extra neben den leuten
spawnen die gerade irgendwie den top
platzierungen sind aber es nervt auf
jeden fall hat er da 431.000 punkte
ist auf jeden fall mehr als ich habe
weil ich habe gerade 29.000 elia ist
gerade links aber ich will ihn einfach
mal sehen vorher töte ich ihnen hier
vorne noch das schließlich einfach so da
habe ich ihn dann getötet jetzt hab ich
30.400 punkte nee das hier das war der
leader
kelly ist braun mit 68.000 das war's vom
video meine damen und herren ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen
meine stimme ist komplett im einmal ich
werde jetzt noch schon deswegen bin ich
auch gerade nicht ausgerastet und so ich
hab mir schon halstabletten gekauft habe
alles schon gemacht also keine sorgen
das wird denke ich morgen wieder besser
sein rechter viel gefallen hat würde ich
mich über eine bewertung freuen dass wir
jetzt mal wieder gaming und nicht um ihr
live deswegen hoffe ich das ist okay und
wir sehen uns im nächsten video wieder
also macht es mut und tschüss